as many as 150 people appeared dead in
northern
india after part of a glacier broke off
and crashed into a dam
in uttarakhand state unleashing floods
waters and debris
eyewitnesses say it happened so fast
that people had almost
no time to react a search for survivors
is underway
amateur video shows the small dam being
swept away by the water and debris
released by the avalanche
[Music]
it then cut further through the area
hitting the hydroelectric power plant in
the valley below
it's feared that people working at the
rishiganga power plant were perhaps
swept away
as well as some villagers
the tragedy happened in the tapovan area
of the northern state of uttarakhand
in northern india this region in the
himalayas is prone to flash floods and
landslides
rescue operations were underway as crews
look for survivors
and tried to secure the area
our correspondent namisha jaiswal is in
delhi following the events in the
district of uttar khan for
us namisha it's difficult to even
imagine these pictures that we're seeing
are truly shocking how dramatic is the
situation
there right now
well rebecca from the updates we're
getting the situation definitely is grim
we have heard about 150 labourers who
were working on one of the power plants
that was hit
another power plant further down has
also been damaged there are also
villages and homes
peppering the banks of the river further
down that could also have been hit
thousands of people from the region have
already been evacuated
teams from the army the border police as
well as disaster response forces have
been deployed
the damage is being assessed and while
authorities claim that flood waters
have already been brought under control
to a certain extent
it's only when all this water actually
recedes that they will be able to assess
the true extent of the damage as well as
the loss of life
yeah you mentioned the flooding there i
mean there's terrifying pictures that
we're seeing
has that flooding really been contained
now or authorities expecting things to
get worse
well so far rebecca authorities are
saying that
what they are insisting on is that
people must not be responding to rumors
about
further flooding or any such or any
determined
information about the loss of life
because they want to ensure that panic
isn't caused
however some information has already
been released saying that further down
the water is below the danger mark so
there is hope that further flooding can
be prevented
further down and there's also dams being
used to
either stall the flow of the water or to
cause for water to be evacuated into a
separate area however the parts of
the river where the water has crashed
through the power
the power generators as well as the dams
have already been severely damaged and
that is where the disaster response
forces will be concentrating
now we know from the i win eyewitness
accounts that it happened so fast that
people didn't really have time
to react but were there any warnings
that something like this might happen
rebecca while there may not have been
immediate warnings there have been
long-term warnings being given by local
uh by local
uh environmentalists as well as
journalists who have pointed out
that an emphasis on tourism in the area
which has led to the whitening of roads
as well as an emphasis on hydel power
projects can lead to disasters and must
be actually be discontinued
the current modi government has actually
been criticized for not coming down more
heavily
on these hydra power plants back in 2013
there was a massive flood episode
in the region the himalayas are after
all an area
that is prone to earthquakes and cloud
bursts and the 2013 episode caused the
loss
of over 5 000 lives and damages to 4 500
villages
so this is of course the region that
does need attention and this disaster
will bring focus back on that fact
all right namisha thanks very much for
the update dw correspondent namisha
j swan in delhi